- [Narrator] Without Abraham
Lincoln, and really his beard,
Milton Bradley, the
godfather of board games
would have never existed.
Bold statement, I know,
but let me explain.
(upbeat music)
The Game of Life.
The spinner, the cars, the choices,
college or career, kids or
no kids, lawyer or farmer.
This family game night staple
was once a pretty morbid game.
Back in the 1800s, Milton Bradley was
in the lithograph business.
Following the Republican
National Convention of 1860,
Bradley printed thousands
of images of Abraham Lincoln
who was clean-shaven at the time.
Shortly thereafter, Lincoln
debuted his iconic beard,
rendering all of Bradley's
prints worthless.
His lithograph business went belly up.
So, Bradley was forced
to try something new.
He came up with a board
game, a seemingly dark
and twisted board game,
appropriately named
The Checkered Game of Life.
The game functioned in a
similar way to how it does now.
There was a spinner,
colored circles that moved
around the board, and of course squares
that could either make you or break you.
The squares on the original
game were overwhelmingly grim,
boasting actions like disgrace, poverty,
ruin, crime, prison, and well, suicide.
Regardless, the game flew off the shelves.
Kids loved it and Milton Bradley went on
to own family game night.
Fast forward to about
a hundred years later.
They revamped the game, trading
Bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones
like payday, or graduation,
which we have all come to know and love.
And so there you have it, the
story of the game called Life.
Thanks, Lincoln.
(bright music)